they're each trying to get into each
other's business how's this gonna work
Brad well this is fundamentally about
future vision and to companies who were
allies now really seeing each other more
as competitors so as you mentioned
Google was an investor in uber a Google
senior executive David Drummond sits on
the uber board but the head of the
self-driving cars project at Google has
been talking with the Detroit Auto Show
and discussing a vision in which these
robotic cars which now may be only a few
years away aren't sold to customers but
are offered as an uber light service so
that's in the future maybe not as far
away as we might like to hope may may be
a couple years away and that has
over-worried because if Google's got a
robot car out there you know that's
probably less expensive pockets right I
mean that's partly that's right here and
the challenges you see in general in the
tech world that someone comes up with
this great innovative idea and the
question is how do you grow it incubate
it to the point where it's big enough
where you don't have to worry about the
competition coming in and stealing it in
uber z-- case already with a forty
billion dollar valuation on it does this
increase its need potentially to go
public well you know what we also saw
this week was uber opening a Research
Center in Pittsburgh with the help of
Carnegie Mellon to investigate the
autonomous vehicle technology and
mapping technology so basically
preparing for a future where they can't
rely on Google for some of these
technologies that's a huge capital
investment Google's got a ten year
headstart potentially I mean they've
raised a lot of money they've had no
problems tapping the private markets I
don't know that it affects the IPO
timeline but at does show that Hoover's
got a lot of work to do if it wants to
catch up and be relevant in a future
where cars are driving themselves will
maybe just go out and make an offer for
uber all right well you know that's a
that's a good question
who knows maybe they have Travis the CEO
of uber has talked about being sort of
determined to be independent of course
there are also other ride-sharing
companies like lyft but look Google has
a ton of data right it has Google Maps
everyone uses Google's technology that's
right and left so dude do they even
would they even need to
to acquire or do they have all the
assets in the tools in house to go spin
this up themselves one day when the
driverless cars already really
interesting you know I had asked Travis
previously about driverless cars and how
it would affect his business going
forward and he had made the point that
this is something that they really
ultimately would be embracing that's
right that he has said that to the
consternation of his driver community
but look I think he's realistic about
the future you know if driverless cars
become a reality and it still seems to
me to be wild science fiction but you
know at CES we know that Ford and
Mercedes and Audi we're all talking
about this being plausible within the
next five years if it becomes a reality
you know who Bruce got to embrace it you
know it's not really a choice because
that's a fundamentally less expensive
ride it's a true alternative to car
ownership that's really overs mission